Florida lawmakers are scrambling to pass
new gun legislation for the first time
in more than a decade after the Parkland
school shooting pro-gun advocates
protested yesterday outside Florida's
Capitol the state Senate is expected to
vote today on a bill that would allow
teachers to be armed and restrict some
gun purchases Nicky batiste is at the
State Capitol in Tallahassee Nicky good
morning good morning bianna proposals to
ban assault style rifles and large
magazines were rejected over the weekend
though it briefly appeared that a pause
on ar-15 sales might pass the
republican-controlled chamber is
bitterly divided but must reach a
compromise by Friday to pass any new
laws speaking at this pro-gun rally
defiant college student 20-year old
Tiffany Berkley fought back against a
potential Florida law that would force
her to wait until she is 21 to buy a gun
raising the age would effectively
terminate any second Amendment rights I
have in this scene during a special
session Florida Senate spent nearly
eight hours amending the Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high school public
safety act the only thing that will help
the situation is if we ban assault
weapons it's not the weapon it's the
evil from within as it stands the
legislation would increase the age to
buy a rifle from 18 to 21 band bum
stocks and require a three day waiting
period for most gun purchases the
legislation will also start a new
marshal program permitting teachers and
staff to be armed after at least 132
hours of training the amendment is
adopted following a voice vote a
two-year ban on ar-15 assault weapons
initially passed but the motion was
reconsidered and reversed 20 minutes
later in a roll call vote
17 days 21 days mr. president the
decision stung for some Florida school
shooting survivors like Jackie Koren who
tweeted this breaks my heart but we will
not let this ruin our movement there
have been students from Stoneman Douglas
here fighting for gun control
what would you say to them you have a
right to be angry I'm angry with you but
we can't have our rights infringed
Brookley says she does support giving
teachers the right to be armed if the
Senate passes the bill today it will
then be considered by the house Gayle
all right Thank You Nicki